china y áfrica vuelven a celebrar una
cumbre en la que se comprometen a
cooperar en los últimos 20 años china ha
ampliado su papel en áfrica
convirtiéndose en su mayor socio
comercial pero solo donde conviene a los
intereses de china por ejemplo en
nigeria porque es un gran productor de
petróleo kenia por sus proyectos de
infraestructura y zambia por su cobre el
comercio ha pasado de menos de 10 mil
millones de dólares a unos 200 mil
millones con un récord establecido en
2013 gracias a la macro inversión en las
iniciativas de cinturones y carreteras
puentes puertos autopistas y presas hoy
en día 1 de cada 3 obras de construcción
en el continente son chinas pero es una
presencia que tiene un precio la
responsabilidad pero también la
dependencia financiera china es el
principal donante de áfrica en los
últimos 20 años beijing han prestado a
los países africanos más de 172 mil
millones de dólares a veces los
préstamos se devuelven en recursos
naturales como el petróleo o el cobalto
con el tiempo esta dependencia ha creado
desconfianza hacia beijing en 2018 la
presencia de china en zambia provocó
manifestaciones
la agenda política de beijing también ha
planteado problemas para algunos después
de que varios países africanos alinearán
su posición con la de china en la onu
otros señalan la corrupción y las leyes
laborales en medio del creciente
descontento el nivel de inversión de
china en áfrica ha caído en picado junto
con el importe de sus préstamos
oficialmente se está culpando de nuevo a
la pandemia pero china comenzó a
retirarse en 2018 mucho antes de que se
produjera el cob y 19